[Music]
an abuse of power news uh uh submitted
by watery water that's a liquidy water
wet water yes a lot of water and it's
judge allegedly tried to cover up sex
with defendants oh hell yeah would that
mean like hey you want to you want to be
a gill innocent then suck my wee-wee
case closed oh so it's abuse of power if
you were to blackmail a judge that's
that's illegal also I'm saying like if I
had to go to jail and that offer was on
the table like I was wanted jail for
like 10-15 years
I suck that dick family or what if you
are not guilty but then because you
didn't want to do it then he's a bad guy
and he makes you guilty
is that what's happening here wait if
you okay so if you [ __ ] that judge and
you blackmail him and it's illegal if
you weren't a good take you to court
that means he won't have to admit to
what you're extorting him for right I
just want to not go to jail because if
you're extorting it like you know extort
him cuz the judge is the one offering
know if I like if he offered me yeah
suck his dick today and then I do it I'm
like okay well now give me money or
someone tell everyone
Oh would he throw himself under the bus
to get out of this no because now it's
his word versus yours and everyone white
cream your ass video if there's a video
if he's a bad judge there's no way you
have a video emails oh I will rig that
hotel room mm-hmm
if he's a shitty judge if you had to go
to jail for two years would you suck a
dick yeah yeah yeah I [ __ ] sit right
here for one month homie yeah dude
internet and I wouldn't mind going to
jail for a week though I've always
wanted to know what it felt like a week
is doable but deep you know twenty
maximum security are we talking about
county jail are we talking about better
on what are we talking about anything I
just want to expand my horizon about
Folsom Prison you're so right
I don't want to expect absolutely not
it's like traveling you know we want to
travel a new places to get new
experiences I've never traveled to
Folsom places so I want to shank it's
not an experience that I would want
admonishing how do you prevent that you
better wear a [ __ ] phone book some of
my friends uh very close friends of ours
that went to the jails
did the job and they're being trained to
become a part of this Fight Club they're
basically gonna be fighting yeah yeah
and it's like the new guys they come in
and then like you know you pair up with
the trainer and stuff and then you're
just forced into doing it and then he
was like thank God I got bailed out
right before that [ __ ] he's all like so
him in my other buddy they've both got
in trouble for the same crime but they
thought it would be really funny to make
them fight each other yeah so they're
like that [ __ ] sucks but you can't
say anything you just got to do it yeah
well so this judge from Tennessee he was
already accused of trading legal favors
for sex but now recently he's facing new
charges for trying to cover up the crime
so this dude's name is casein KC
Moreland KC's what casein that's an
interesting that's the name of a protein
it's a slow digesting protein yeah judge
casein what a weird name our judge more
than that looks like it's melting man
I've always wanted to feel what that
skin looks it feels like I can't want to
squish it Danny Shady it's probably
softest [ __ ] doing grandma's get the
[ __ ] into Turkey now mm-hmm
yeah older your skin gets really thin
i'ma get it dude actually stabbed an old
lady on the plane one oh my god how'd
you do that because how'd you even get a
knife on the plane that ridiculous I
would never heard of seen this visit so
when I went to Germany my nail artist
decides to give you the bat [ __ ] was not
dopest you remember that right yeah she
wasn't
pointy right so we're sitting like I'm
sitting next to his old lady she's like
70 years old and I go and then and then
like I'll say oh sorry I scratch it or
like I poked you a little bit and then
like blue but I say she goes hey look
what you did
and then she's bleeding it I like she's
like an older white lady I was like oh
my god that's gonna take on nine months
to heal that's what I'm saying like how
the first thing you think about is I'm
against - no I was like what she's white
I'm gonna get sued like I didn't know
she's I was so scared like I'm gonna get
sued I just said I should I have a lady
on a plane this is so bad I was like oh
my god like she had like a jacket and go
through a few hundred trees I'll fly
your trick I'll buy you [ __ ]
torturing so Jack and coaches the sleds
occasionally and then so I called oh no
excellent it's got some other changes
it's not champagne gin and tonic gin
talking in trouble the flight attendants
like can I please have a band-aid and
then like I put it on here I'm like you
want a drink you she was really cool so
just so like we ended up talking the
whole entire way through and their
flight I'm like oh my god I'm so glad I
met you it's sometimes I guess it's
pretty cool I stab you and I'm just like
why'd you say that
she started laughing like thank God
because I think she was kind of like
already tipsy she'll really slow yeah
dude like I probably that whole is gonna
be there till she died mm-hmm her arms
party getting a putative right now
that's just [ __ ] still bleeding in
her [ __ ] coffin she was a male they
lost it [ __ ] of course you did you
terrible person you know you probably
want to go clubbing with you too no you
make me feel young again
I got a young girl friends she was so
cool she was part is 27 - I know you're
calling her a [ __ ] Jesus
she's like just she was like a Vegas
waitress she just weathered really hard
she's wearing like a [ __ ] Duke
University sweater like all she viewed
it was like one week asleep and she was
just gonna write back okay oh my god
poor old lady and then I just got that
with my finals
alright back to the old guy back to this
one got him - yes apparently he traded
sexual favors with two women to get rid
of their traffic tickets like little
[ __ ] for a traffic ticket only women I
was talking jail time yeah fines in
court yo traffic tickets can be a lot of
money they'll [ __ ] you up your insurance
goes up all that stuff I don't want to
point on my insurance you think about
the aftermath mmm yeah like they even
had like some sex exchange like for
example with one of them like with two
women right but one of them ended up
committing suicide oh no [ __ ] maybe keep
on had a smelly dick I don't know but
then like the two girls were friends so
then the other like the friend says that
um like there was text exchanges there
was this one where the one I had
committed suicide she had asked like
what are you doing tomorrow between 3:30
and 5:30 after she her tickets were
wiped and he was like just be horny and
naked oh you're like a thousand years
old dude but he's still horny how do you
know he's a thousand you see the way you
looked
mm Joel doesn't mean they don't they
can't get their dick wet he was also
embezzling cash from this foundation
that's at his job
yeah how do you uphold the lawn there
like the worst break the law yeah
welcome to the world of laws and then
once you learn that he was being
investigated by the FBI he was was the
sorriest how to process that for a
second I was like welcome to the police
of policing oh he did it
wait did you actually hit it or did what
happen when he when he was investigated
no II was being investigated he
instructed the Foundation's director to
destroy documents that showed how much
he stole and he also totally do it
he also told witnesses lied to the grand
jury yeah so funny that's kind of like I
stole from you it's like hate if I'm
getting in trouble can you
not totally Winona stole this director
that was like he was telling this
director to embezzle cash right so he
would all they came down teamed up
because then this person was allowed to
increase her own compensation from the
foundation where is this
Sanofi keeping is so caught up they
don't have backups like when that starts
to happen you just need to send like one
color like croissant like she just
texted course on I don't know what to do
start chopping [ __ ] up they probably
didn't think it through because he's
above the law I like it when people that
are abusing power getting big abuse I
hope he gets abused in jail oh and he
saw the people he put away even
knowledge it works
I'd be more angry at the jury than the
judge well these are traffic tickets and
[ __ ] it's not like jury a bowl oh it's
one of those judges yeah because if I
got guilty and then it had a jurors I'll
be like [ __ ] you guys yeah I mean the
judge is just there like I see him as a
referee it's not his call it's like when
who was it was a chapel or was in one oh
crap oh the El Chapo or there's another
one here let's go bar yeah when he was
like no I promise not to harm the jury's
family and I was like uh okay like it's
like that way it's amazing I know right
like that that's [ __ ] power
terrifying dude I am leaving that jury
duty immediately I would just scream
someone else's guilty yeah my name is
Jason Chen bye I'm a singer on YouTube
on YouTube that's me just never sleeps
[Laughter]
it's Gary that's insane he also denied
but with sexual relations okay yeah
right they should just test the [ __ ]
jokes on his upper lip wrinkles
that [ __ ] saliva [ __ ] crawled in his
[ __ ] life yo he's a giant is he 6 6
oh holy [ __ ] I was like Dan that dick
was huge 6 6 it probably small in
comparison to his body but that's still
gonna be a whopper of a penis huh are
you sure you like a lot of tall people
like or short people feel bad it's gonna
be 66 inches then oh that's so that's
like five six so that's not true geo
short doesn't mean a little dick cuz I
saw this little person poor that's what
I'm saying
no I'm just saying this person to his
size but if he's like six foot six
whenever a small dick is to him my feel
pretty big penis yep getting away from
that well then it was easy for the girls
in what they complain about just doing
that that nasty sack of skin is on you
know even if you're old your dick is
still hard though I saw a porn like that
I was like wow why do you watch this
[ __ ] Joseph I don't read the titles I
don't read the titles yeah but the
thumbnail shows you the [ __ ] old no
sometimes it's just someone on someone's
like writing them or like it's just a
it's like a close-up and I go oh that's
a nice toasty in the Wikipedia of your
feet you know you have a foot Kapadia
she does all of us do but what does that
have to do with watching nest you find
weird [ __ ] online man
what do you mean the Wikipedia Murphy
there's something called wiki feet calm
and all of us have pages on there even
me I don't know
I haven't checked the guys yet I'm not
on he look it was just an elephant foot
like a foot fetish yeah that's always
and they rate you I wonder if girls are
worried about like YouTube girls
remember we did that article about that
[ __ ] uh what's it called ah the
reddit the reddit guy that was doing a
celebrity porn face oh yeah I think one
of the girls are doing that too like the
YouTube community TV have already they
did one of me well I'm behind I'm so bad
and what it's like deep fix of our sites
my body's better than this [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] I actually didn't get to see it
because people were DME we've but by the
time I looked at it the reddit went down
I didn't even look at it I would have
been offended like man my dick is way
bigger than that [ __ ] huh they
don't do it already more they've run at
that page down it's not real
hey don't get me hard
[Music]